so let's go
let's go to the bone end of the week
here
and let's let's start the bone end of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's edition of
bonehead of the week sorry it's taken us
a minute to get here
was your head i don't know i don't know
i apologize i apologize
to everyone who is listening i'm so
sorry are you are you on your are you on
your regular microphone yeah i'm on my
regular mic now okay okay you you don't
sound you don't sound like uh you're on
your regular the the the the normal mic
this one i can't can you yeah yeah i can
hear you oh it sounds good oh it's
working now oh yeah it's working put
your headphones on yeah okay here we go
yeah yeah well you know
there we go
there we go oh
for the people watching i apologize this
is just the ultimate user error this
morning yeah right well we're going to
blame it all on you because yeah no i
mean listen i'm sitting here on a chair
i've seen her on the air [ __ ] die in
here
waiting we want the phone
listen if we want to cancel this and
just call me the bonehead of the week
we'll just do that that's fine you know
you're getting there usually and and i i
had a troll i don't know if you noticed
this but i had a troll in the in the
comments section of the bone of the week
poll
i'm talking about yeah that saying d
tony michaels that i of course you know
most weeks i am the [ __ ] bonehead
right yeah this weekend there's the
debate here who the bonehead on the show
is well it's me i mean sometimes usually
it's you and today it is what the f okay
well i see how it is
so so let's let's get into the bone end
of the week because please we have three
people that are on the bonehead of the
week but literally there's only one
there's only one person i mean if we
look take a look here
rand paul from the start he just
kicked it out of the gate and we just
like the first 10 minutes wasn't it i
don't know we got like 100 votes or
something like that in the first 10 or
50 it was pretty much decided listen i
know i'm no mathematician but you know
you know the thing here is gabe you know
and i don't i don't mean to push the
blame on anything but you've had like
you've had like four days here four days
because you've known who this was yeah i
did that wasn't the issue though i had
other i've got other work going on you
know yeah yeah but also it's my it's my
it was my mic and my headset they're
labeled
i don't know they're they just don't
show up how they're supposed to on my
computer it's causing major confusion
i'm saying
oh yeah yeah major confusion live
this you know but this is live shows
this is why live because this is how it
works i feel like whenever something
goes wrong we should just cut to the
clip like we should have it ready
where it's uh bill o'reilly and he's
like [ __ ] it we'll do it live we'll do
it live do it live [ __ ] it live so we
had three boneheads center rand paul
hulk hogan and james o'keefe of course
these are all you know reoccurring
boneheads these aren't just like
boneheads now they've always no james i
mean yeah always been a bonehead though
james o'keefe kind of
he did he hasn't really had anything
come out
on
uh
since like one of those like undercover
uh in a hospital a doctor said this
[ __ ] you know well cal call the
audience who james o'keefe is because
yeah oh actually you know what he did
have a reoccurrence at the tpusa thing
right where they came out dancing to the
weekend so oh yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
video anything right yeah yeah
ymca type [ __ ] it's really [ __ ] weird
they're like
it's the
hercules it's like the
they called it the the veritas
the the uh veritas experience they had a
[ __ ] name for the dance yeah well i
mean it was like what their like thing
they were featured you know and then
here he is like
giving some sort of narration as people
go out anyway for people who don't know
james o'keefe
is the uh the person behind
uh project veritas yeah the domestic
terrorist group yeah right exactly the
russian propaganda machine yep i get it
yeah so he's the one behind that and uh
yeah for context for people who didn't
watch or didn't you know save themselves
from watching the tpusa kyle rittenhouse
[ __ ] jizz fest uh
it was
it was
i mean that's what it was let's be
honest right well yeah it was a charlie
kirk circle jerk yeah exactly yeah and
then you had a
a drunk questionably drunk uh tucker
carlson come out and talk uh maybe
possibly yeah 100
i feel like
i feel like you'd have to be drunk to be
there anyway so what he what what james
o'keefe did was they
you know
brought everyone out they're like oh
here's a whistleblower from cnn and
here's a whistle blower from cbs and
here's this and here's that and they all
came out dancing to that weekend song
that was like this song at the super
bowl last year
and oh and the in the uh in like the
mirror maybe yeah exactly right right
yeah yeah uh and so
and also the one that everyone like
danced to on tick tock the one where
they're like
you know i don't know
right you know you're the dance
professional
if anyone doesn't know gabe does a lot
of tick tock videos but if you scroll
all the way down to the bottom of his
feed there are dance videos there if you
see how far the rabbit hole goes okay
anyways anyway so james o'keefe
the moral of the story here is before
rand paul senator rand paul did what he
did and anthony fauci dr anthony fauci
dunked him in the [ __ ] trash um
project veritas released a video it was
like i don't know six hours before that
um it was definitely coordinated the
other thing that the coordination is
concerning
is that senator rand paul seems to be
part of that coordination which all this
is russian propaganda they're talking
about [ __ ] vaccines and all you know
all this veritas you know china virus
and all this [ __ ] you know just this
[ __ ] garbage that that dr fauci
dunked in the trash and it's all
coordinated effort you can tell it's
coordinated they knew and rand paul knew
that that video was gonna trend and i
forget the [ __ ] hashtag it doesn't
matter project veritas produced a
[ __ ] russia propaganda video against
dr fauci and then that that next morning
and what's funny about it
and almost all these project veritas how
you know it's russian propaganda is they
release it
at a time when a certain country is
awake right yeah so like if you get
stopped you get the farm running baby
you know right right those the the
russian troll bot farms are [ __ ]
awake and going at one o'clock in the
morning when it's when it's one o'clock
in the morning here so let's let's go to
because we got you know we got this
other bonehead hulk hogan um and he was
trending and i think i think
hey everyone question why is he trending
in some of the comments and i'm like
look this is important stuff why he's
trending because
um
this is the crazy [ __ ] that they're that
is happening in parts of the internet
um dave 50 shades away here of course he
says
famous epidemiologist
dr hulk hogan
implies that betty white and city potty
passed away because of the vaccine which
is [ __ ] despicable number one get
your [ __ ] get betty white's name and
sydney patty's name out your [ __ ]
mouth number one but here's hulk hogan
and you can see the verified camera that
says 100 betty and sydney
were also jabbed they're dropping like
flies or is that
he says also jamed
well yeah okay well right
well i mean you read it how you want to
read it i'll read it how i want to read
it and 100
better yeah sydney we're all so jamed
they're dropping like flowers
that has injected probably every orifice
on his body with steroids all of a
sudden says hey hold up
we'll kill you
don't don't trust it because you don't
know what's in the needle because he
knows a lot about not knowing what's in
the [ __ ] it's like can you list off
the ingredients that are in the steroids
maybe you can but also you also
know that they're not the best for you
right right right well i mean obviously
this right it's gotten to this guy's
head and this [ __ ] meathead has
gotten to his head but i and i'm not
sure what is this on is this this is
facebook okay this is this yeah this is
ivermecton institute right here okay so
this is the facebook ivermecton
institute that i'm always talking about
and you know what you know what also
this is
this is literally
i keep saying it i say it all time the
intersection of wrestlemania and real
life and we have it right [ __ ] here
right in front of us
hogan is making it's bone-headed
oh
he really suplexed us there right yeah
no everyone knows that city potty potty
and betty white were in their [ __ ]
90s like exactly this isn't this isn't
hard to understand yeah that the reason
why
betty and sydney passed away
and just do us all a favor and stop
being a [ __ ] idiot and get them out
of your [ __ ] mouth hulk
let me give um because i think i
actually did but we'll get bonehead
tweet here i think i gave
dave here um
shitless uh credit yeah see there's the
[ __ ] list credit he's on the show twice
wow look at that
hey it's important big time big time
it's important it's important stuff um
but we we want to go to let's do our um
i'm sorry
viagra is not currently recommended for
covenant teacher oh no [ __ ]
speak speaking speaking of hulk hogan
and and [ __ ] kobe 19 treatments uh
maybe maybe they're singing a signal to
hulk hogan there hey dude yeah your
viagra he's about to he's about to pop a
load man he's like
oh my god
yeah you know that we went to the cat
turd thing right yeah yeah earlier on
the show you know we had one of the most
the best interview coach it's gonna air
tonight at eight o'clock eastern the
interview with rachel
and we led into the interview with
[ __ ] cat turds it was yeah that's
quality
quality [ __ ] right if that's what we do
here on this show if you so if you want
to go watch the cat turd conversation
before the interview you're gonna have
to go to the youtube channel and
subscribe over there to make sure that
you catch the entire podcast episode to
get the cat turd conversation before the
interview but tonight at eight o'clock
it'll be just the interview trivia
interview with rachel the second half is
she blows she blows you she'll blow your
mind yeah and what she's saying and why
it makes sense um we have a dishonorable
mention this week
um mad dog yeah daddy
maddie man well
i have heard some people say i don't
know who it is and i don't know who
floated this out there it's not my
nickname i'm just saying that i've heard
people say this you know this is what
the [ __ ] they do i have heard people say
this that his nickname is shitler
sittler shitler hitler is hitler hitler
hitler hitler yeah i've heard of the
other things too yeah yeah um maybe
power wheels or something but i you know
i'm not going to go there i'm not i'm
not i'm not going to go i'll let other
people go yeah yeah uh that let's see so
um madison calder why was he on our [ __ ]
list near the bone end of the week
oh because he said that he was able to
he would he would love well this is what
happened there
he was like i want to debate rachel
maddow and then after that he goes uh
oh
some emails got leaked and rachel
maddow's now
running away scared from debating me
what was the emails i don't i just i
don't have cable right i don't know i
don't have i don't have cables i don't
know what i don't watch everything they
just said like an inside source i don't
even know if they showed what the emails
were i just hear all these [ __ ]
tweets and things of him they're just
just yelling out loud and they're just
saying
oh
inside inside source says that uh rachel
maddow is scared to debate because
they're afraid they're like she would it
was like rachel they said rachel maddow
wouldn't wouldn't i didn't want to bring
him on the show because or didn't want
to mention his name because then he
would have to comment on it or something
like that
like he would go on the show anyways
look do they understand that rachel mano
now i i've watched rachel before i don't
watch her now because i don't have cable
but do they understand that rachel
maddow is a [ __ ] road scholar right
so that's what happened so this thing
got brought up and they're like dude
you lied about getting to the naval
academy you're not too smart you claim
to be a historian but get all your facts
wrong and and your quotes wrong rachel
maddow will [ __ ] run laps around you
she's a rhodes scholar oh my god [ __ ]
hella smart
uh
so people were on that side they're like
oh he's he's gonna he's gonna you know
do laps around it's like dude she no
that's not what you think is gonna
happen i mean she could take the time
you know i mean it's probably for the
same reason that aoc is like
i'm not gonna give you the time of day
because it's only going to
bring up your platform right that you're
on
even though like
you know uh let's just call what it is
marger taylor green's a [ __ ] idiot
and no
not her not her foot okay well you know
i guess jury's still out oh i'm sorry
jerry just came back there's a
conspiracy there's a conspiracy going
around right right
conspiracy going around so i've been
avenger resistor i i think this is what
he he's getting to the heart of the
matter in the couple right in a couple
lines here if rachel maddow de meadow
debated madison cawthorne
she would eat him alive and save the
trees
thank you avenger resistor for putting
us in at the right spot
there oh that's not what we want the
right spot
for
we got a lot of technical difficulties
here today thanks for putting us in the
right spot for this dishonorable mention
now let's go to let's go to the hero of
the week the real bone end of the week
uh our winner rand paul yeah well
there's a lot of reasons why this
[ __ ] should be bonehead of the
year bonehead of the century but that
there is a specific reason why he's the
bone of the week but let's do something
real first
let's give him his due
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so congratulations to rand paul for
winning bonehead bonehead oh my god i
just it's it is really funny when i'm
making the graph like i look at the poll
and i'm like yeah it's pretty big but
then when you see it actually play out
right you're like this
is hysterical it looks like he is like a
big huge [ __ ] right because yeah no yeah
no definitely yeah
it looks like yeah yeah
uh it's just funny because you look at
in comparison like james o'keefe got
like one point something percent and
he's like barely moving and you're like
is it working and then meanwhile paul
ryan or rand paul just like
just streaming he's cruising dude he he
came out of the gates and never [ __ ]
quit he he i think this is probably the
biggest blowout we've had on bonehead of
the week yeah last week was the was the
biggest because it was like
56
28 14.
and so that was the closest one that
we've had was last week and then this
week is the biggest blowout i think so
yeah all right well go check out those
other episodes to to correct us if we're
wrong
but there's wrong we'll be the bonehead
yeah yeah sure well you're definitely
the bonehead of the day
um so the reason why rand paul though is
won the bonehead of the week so quickly
is because of what he he attempted to do
after the project veritas video drops
and this is nothing new either like he's
tried to pull this [ __ ] multiple times
before and this was about you just be
like you know i'm [ __ ] tired of this
right well you know and we talked about
this earlier on in the week because you
know i keep i keep saying over and over
that politics and government are two
different things and rand paul tries to
play politics with anthony fauci and
anthony fauci is like i'm not a [ __ ]
politician i'm government i do the
government thing you're the politician
stop playing politics with me do the
government thing with me you go play
politics someplace else but he plays
politics in these [ __ ]
uh these committee hearings when he
could actually get to some truth and ask
ask some actual [ __ ] questions so
that his constituents and the american
people could be aware of what actually
is going on and what anthony fauci knows
but he wastes time doing this dumb
[ __ ] thing where he presses
misinformation and lies about anthony
fauci somehow a murderer whatever and
that's really what the [ __ ] biggest
boneheaded thing is here that
and and anthony voucher dunks him in the
trash because dr fauci has not really
participated in the politics up until
this moment he always slams him he
always dunks him he always goes back to
the truth but he's never actually went
to the heart of the politics of this and
rand paul i mean it looks like his
[ __ ] neighbor punched him in the
[ __ ] face
when
when dr fauci dunks him in the trash
here um lincoln project has the video so
let's go ahead and play their version of
it here
why would senator want to do this
so go to
rand paul website
and you see
fire dr foucher with a little box that
says contribute here you can do five
dollars ten dollars twenty dollars a
hundred dollars so you are making a
catastrophic epidemic for your political
gains uh [ __ ] yeah politically
i'm the victim
i'm so sad
the the the funniest part about what
fouchy does there
is he
he he does he does like the the you know
the the street corner the sign guy this
drilling sign guy he's like five dollars
ten dollars twenty dollars you decide
push the button you know he's like like
found he's all into selling this thing
right yeah like fauci's the straight guy
here and he went all in on the sale of
that rand paul is pumping out [ __ ]
propaganda so he can make money here is
the the slam dunk was fantastic the
other great thing about this
and he's gone but the other thing why we
get why we wait for gabe come back the
other great thing about what happened
here in this video is that
every every what what what's going on
what is i know what's happening with it
so so uh
the eat jet printer thing so anthony
fauci if you watched it let's go back
i'm going to pause this year but we said
i mean we said this what was it
yesterday too look at this years ago he
[ __ ] used an ejet printer to print
this [ __ ] out he's like listen i'm going
to use government resources to print
this out because i am the government do
you think it's government inc that he
used yeah for sure
that's high quality inc baby right
no no way did he use personal link he
totally used government because you know
anthony fauci is a monster right yeah no
way terrible i mean he's been profiting
off this pandemic from the start you
know right well you know that's the
other thing that we talked about earlier
on the week and i've been saying this
forever is that none of these [ __ ]
idiots out there that have demonized
anthony fatchy i think he's some kind of
murderer some some just nonsense just
[ __ ] complete dribble right no if you
really
knew your [ __ ] you would know that the
only reason why we know doctor who dr
fauci is is because donald trump [ __ ]
up the actual pandemic response in 2020.
if he would have done what he was
supposed to do and listen to dr fauci
he would have been the hero
and no one would know who the [ __ ] dr
fauci is right but donald trump is a
fuck-up and he always has to have a fall
guy you know what it reminds me of and
rather i guess you know who reminds me
of trump is ron desantis right where
they where they get called out about
like hey there's like there's like a
million tests that are just in a
warehouse and they're like that's not
true that's not true then they have the
press conference the next day and like
yo what's up with that what's up with
stuff in the the warehouse and they're
like uh actually you know what uh he's
gonna take it and then right away and
he's like yes there were a million tests
and it's like it's just like when you're
giving a group presentation and you go
around and everyone does their part and
then you don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about and you're like and
uh yeah it's kind of like it's kind of
like when you're doing a live show and
someone's
supposed to have their [ __ ] together
i did have it together
i just couldn't get on it was the video
and the audio problem i'm not selling
the audio in the microprocessor
it's clearly the fall guy yeah right
clearly i just everyone watching
listening uh please just be team gabe on
this uh i wasn't the one that's at fault
yeah well you know let's give rand paul
his one last due
um here this is the only time he'll ever
be in a race that he'll win in that's
true
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay well
that concludes this version first
version of the second hour of a two-hour
show of bone end of the week i i i think
next week we will probably
have maybe a little more things sorted
out we really didn't yeah any impre we
didn't practice this that much no no no
but also yeah
i got other stuff going you know i got
all the work going on
here's here's the fall guy here's the
phone yeah here i am i'm just making
excuses yeah you know i need that i need
my excuse yeah i know i know well that
concludes the bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
all right all right well thanks for
joining us uh for the first two hour
edition with bonehead of the week on
friday we're going to continue to do
bonehead of the week on friday and i
think what we'll do to also is we'll cut
out bone in the week like post it
separate i was talking about that
earlier posted separate um but don't for